let's talk about a new law in france
that they want to bring in
it's called reinforcing republican
principles
the french president says it's about
preventing religious extremism
islamists the bill doesn't actually
single out any one religion
but some french muslims say it's
targeting them and that it's being used
to score political points
a good muslim is an invisible muslim in
this country so what's in this proposed
law
is it as bad as some people say and what
does it have to do with france's whole
thing about
[Music]
secularism
when it comes to religions france is a
pretty diverse place
just over half its population identifies
as christian it has the largest muslim
and jewish communities in europe
and a third of people in france don't
affiliate with any faith at all
and all of those communities have been
able to coexist in part because of a
legal principle called
laicite which roughly translates as
secularism
it was passed into law in 1905 to
separate the french republic from the
catholic church after years of power
struggles
these days you can see leicester in
action in the way the french president
for example
isn't sworn in using a holy book
leicester is a great concept in itself
the state remains neutral the people
working for the states
the civil servant remains
neutral the people however
are not neutral the and actually it's a
way
to protect religious freedom freedom to
believe
to not believe but over the years french
governments have interpreted lycite in
new ways
they brought in all kinds of measures to
keep religion out of public life
to the point though that some people
accuse the state of going after religion
like a law in 2004 that banned religious
symbols
in public schools large christian
crosses the muslim headscarf
sikh turbans jewish skull caps the
kippah all were banned in
the name of leicester secularism so from
a tool a legal tool that
was aimed to protect religious freedom
it became a tool to
target religious visibility it goes back
to
a centuries-old pattern of how the
french government has tried to control
religion
so what does leicester or secularism
have to do with this new bill
well the proposed law doesn't explicitly
mention leicester
but it talks about republican principles
like free thinking and free speech
which president emmanuel macron says are
under threat
because of terrorism since 2015 more
than 200 people in france have been
killed
mostly by attackers recruited or
inspired by isil or al-qaeda
[Music]
like the attack on staff at the
satirical magazine charlie abdo
it had published caricatures of the
prophet muhammad whose depiction is
widely forbidden in islam
90 people killed at the bounticon
theater a truck driven through crowds
a christmas market shooting and then
there was
everything that happened in 2020.
charlie abdul republished the prophet's
caricature and two people were stabbed
outside the magazine's old building
that's when macron announced he was
drafting this bill
but that didn't go down well with
leaders in muslim-majority countries
spread and some people boycotted french
products
it is absolutely unacceptable to hurt
the sentiments of millions of muslims
across the world
in the name of freedom of speech not
long afterwards a teacher in france
showed students the caricature during a
lesson about free speech
there was a social media campaign
against him he was tracked down and
beheaded
and then a week later several people
were killed inside a church
so macron went ahead and proposed his
bill he gave the problem
a name islamist separatism and explained
it this way
okay so what's in this proposed law
things like tougher penalties for people
who threaten or attack public workers in
the name of religion
more powers to go after hate speech
online and limits on big foreign
donations to religious institutions
but there's other stuff in there like
giving officials more power to stop
forced marriages
polygamy and anyone issuing virginity
certificates for women about to marry
yes forced marriage uh is a horrible
thing but guess what we already have
laws for that
polygamy is already prohibited on a
french law
it's the same with uh you know fighting
terrorism
we have a very strong legal apparatus
that apparently was not enough efficient
to prevent other terrorist attacks
there are even restrictions on religious
private schools and homeschooling
it's easy to find some examples of
somebody who you know ends up
with isis who was homeschooled by her
parents or his parents
you can find examples of anything how
much of a real problem this is i think
much more is being made of this than
most people in the educational field
would support
that's the thing about this bill it
seems to be about a lot of things
lysitee terrorism mosques schools women
even what the politicians describe as
separatism
some take that to mean everything from
radicalized young people
to communities not assimilating even as
far as how halal and kosher food
are stopped separately
it goes back to this theme that muslims
refused to really integrate
if they were to integrate they wouldn't
publicly proclaim
themselves to be different and it's not
just this bill
there's a lot more going on the
government has closed down several
mosques and muslim associations for
having radical links
which they've denied they've also got
muslim religious leaders to agree on a
charter of principles that rejects
political islam and foreign interference
this is something french presidents like
to do
they build monuments they build museums
they build councils to govern islam
it's almost a routine they started by
organizing
the catholic church then it was
judaism and now it's muslims so how do
muslims in france feel about all of this
well religious leaders are split one
muslim association said
separatism is a reality that must be
faced
at the same time a lot of people feel
this bill just reinforces a feeling that
french muslims
but if you listen to french commentators
there's another theory about why
macron's pushing this bill
it's that ahead of elections in 2022
he's making a political calculation to
win support
on the far right and on the left france
is complicated because
it's actually a portion of the left
which tends to be most
kind of strict about secularism this
could grab some
some secularist parts on the left you
can grab some far right
it's hard to square these things though
because you can only go so far in
in appeasing everybody france's
parliament and senate still have to vote
on the bill
before it becomes law they'll have to
weigh up a lot of things but chief among
them
is whether this proposed law goes
against the very principles people say
it's trying to defend
we love hearing about what you'd like us
to explain next we're actually working
on some of your ideas now
so if you come across any news stories
you find complicated
let us know in the comments wherever
you're watching this video and i'll see
you next week